in my town
we had a game called the squid game roll
commercial wait is this on netflix what
the [ __ ] do we roll on netflix maybe
roll credits that they'll never let you
watch unless you take the time to find
the resume credits section when the
option should actually be skip credits
and then if i want to watch the [ __ ]
credits i can without being hassled by
algorithms and netflix's insane need to
get views counted on people didn't want
to watch but fell asleep or wandered out
of the room so the thing started anyway
and now ridiculous 6 has been viewed 300
million times because people can't just
watch [ __ ] credits and make better
choices with their follow-up selections
also let's address the distractingly
american-sounding squid-shaped elephant
in the room that's our decision to send
the english dubbed version of the show
instead of leaving it in the much better
original korean okay now that that's
addressed on with the sitting it's your
mom your mom if an attacker cuts through
the waste of the squid past the defense
then they are given the freedom to use
both feet what in the name of all that
is calamari are these rules that's a
[ __ ] kids game whatever happened to
[ __ ] tag you're it
[Music]
man just really leaning into the ip or
ripping off huh why not just give him
the first name of battle and be done
with it if someone on the defense
manages to push you outside of the
squid's boundaries
you die
that's right
you die over exaggerating for dramatic
effect right
right
vanity or bragging take your pick i
sincerely apologize if i'm missing some
well-known south korean subspecies of
this marine animal but on what [ __ ]
planet is this a squid the nose isn't
nearly big enough remember
gaeung's birthday is today yeah of
course i do the girl whose birthday it
is is his [ __ ] daughter just thought
that was worth mentioning in case his
reaction to this news understandably had
you thinking this person was his ex-wife
or satan please select the amount you
would like
inspector royale did i use it right damn
it ah the old woman cares about her
granddaughter more than her own son and
this is surprising to him in the space
of three minutes he's guilted her into
giving him more of her own money so he
can buy a present for his daughter
harassed her for daring to have a job
and stolen her [ __ ] credit card i
mean what's not to love choosing to show
gambling addiction with people shouting
while watching a horse race only to be
disappointed their sure bet didn't come
through cliche
hey kid you okay finding a hole in his
jacket doesn't immediately mean it was
stolen by this person why couldn't have
just fallen out while he was running
i'm being foreshadowed at aren't i also
there's so little contact here i can't
see how she could have possibly slightly
handed her away into cutting open his
jacket pocket and grabbing that envelope
also also gee whiz she must be the
luckiest pickpocket in south korea she's
just managed to accidentally herself
into a huge amount of cash by simply
being in the way there's no chance she
could have known that he was going to
run through here or bump into her or
which pocket to pick once he did poor
thing
excuse me sir
you need to stop and pick the prize you
want first this kid in the web of lies
he weaves these claw machines were
crafted as a result of a singular never
to be repeated alliance between lady
luck and satan himself their goal was to
create the most efficient way to suck
the soul from a person's body via their
wallet while their disappointed
offspring watch on wishing they had
better parents it's only redeeming
quality is that the second you give up
the next worker that uses it is
immediately rewarded just in case you
thought you'd be able to move on and
live a normal life stop and pick the
prize you want first indeed
[Music]
this [ __ ] picked a mystery black box
when stitch is right [ __ ] there
aggressively hugging a child you do not
know without explicit consent
what's up
huge mosquito bite pencil i had no idea
that mosquitoes even had fists let alone
use them for biting
i know siang isn't going to win any
father of the year awards but why would
he not check what this present is before
handing it over even if it hadn't been a
gun the odds of it being something that
his daughter wouldn't care for are
pretty [ __ ] high it again raises the
question why did he even pick the
mystery box in the first place when
stitch was right there
holy sh did she just pull the trigger
not knowing it was a lighter i'll give
all the sins back if we eventually find
out gaeung is the head of the squid
games hello sir
can i talk to you rumor has it it's
taken this man many many years to
recruit seong into the squid games as a
result of choosing this [ __ ]
approach every day he's had to wait in
this train station for hours at a time
just hoping xiang will finally miss a
train you've got to feel sorry for him
it's time after time xiang would make
his scheduled departure and this poor
chap would be left to sadly walk home
shamefully hanging his head thinking nah
next time that'll be the time that i get
him just you wait and see i don't
believe in jesus hey you i demand that
you clap your hands right this instant
wait was that for saving jesus or
fairies would you like to play a game
with me agreeing to play a game with
anyone at a subway station at night this
doc she's on for all the some time
[Music]
inspector royale
that's still not right damn it 160
million won owed just to loan sharks
and you owe 250 more to the bank
exchange rates and inflation are wild
man i've spent every other minute
googling juan to dollars trying to work
out just how screwed saint is the answer
is very to the tune of about 350
thousand dollars now i have to sin the
show for making me do math in my leisure
time to that in the remainder of the
sins in this video will be converted to
sin won with the current exchange rate
that'll be 1187 sinwon to each usn i've
rounded down because the show is pretty
great you're welcome look what i got
[Laughter]
kion what'd you do now
you gamble again did you look at me like
that didn't compulsive liars he got into
seoul national university thanks to me i
used to take him to school when we were
there's always that one [ __ ] that
manages to ride on the coattails of the
successful and claim that their tiny
contribution was integral to said
success i mean it's not like he created
a youtube channel dedicated to pointing
out the overused cliches and errors in
popular media now that would be a
contribution we're celebrating i got
that with money i made getting slept so
enjoy it thing i said to my parents
after giving them their christmas
presents i bought with the money i made
for my first sex tape somehow makes its
way into the episode who you are
gambling again
of course not it's still too early to
tell if sang is an [ __ ] or not so the
director told him to shove as much rice
into his mouth as possible just before
he starts talking while the audience
makes up their mind i talked to that
young man upstairs who knows the law and
he said that
the father
has to show the child will have
financial support and
when you can prove that
then you can take custody but if the
divorce is final and the custody has
already been decreed it'll take a lot
more than extra money to get the custody
overturned did he also suggest planning
heroin on the mother's person because
that would have a better chance of
working or so i've heard i can see why
wanting to keep his daughter would
motivate seong to try to win this money
but a one-off cash payment isn't going
to convince the courts to give him
custody if anything it's going to look
even more suspicious that this
unemployed man who struggles to keep a
job down suddenly has a bajillion
trillion wand to his name if they're
running this gas every time a new person
gets in the van then the other people
are just getting re-gassed how do they
ensure they aren't bringing any dead
contestants to the game i'd be
questioning the efficiency of this
company immediately after waking up in
this room look at all this unused space
amateurs this entire operation looks
like it's been kitted out with a bunch
of repurposed pac-man and galaga arcade
machines that scar on your neck you're
the damn pickpocket at this point seong
should be well aware that he has had his
clothing and personal belongings taken
and that everyone else seems to be in a
similar position so why does he expect
this woman to still have his money who
the hell
who are you
trying to have a tough guy scene when
everyone is wearing tracksuits
you took all our stuff and put us to
sleep coming here and then you brought
us to this strange warehouse now you're
saying you'll pay us if we go and play a
few games you really expect us to buy
that did this guy not get the same pitch
that cyan got okay the loss of
consciousness and sudden change of
clothing might have been a surprise but
what did you think you were signing up
for if it wasn't this
night school we do not disclose the
faces and personal information of our
staff to any of the participants except
for this guy in charge of recruitment
who has the most public facing of jobs
because
that guy also if anonymity is so
important why go through the risk and
effort of using this recruitment method
at all judging by this crowd there
doesn't seem to be a shortage of
desperate people with debts they can't
afford to pay off doesn't look like
there was any need for this hard sell at
all i think most of these people would
have responded to the business card if
it was just posted through their door
with a note attached saying ring this
number for cash this is now the second
occasion of seong signing a contract
with a shady criminal or criminals makes
me wonder why said criminals are even
bothering with said contracts with
contractual consequences that vary from
light maiming to death surely they can't
be legally binding i would have loved to
be in this designer meeting what are you
thinking for styles and colors well have
you ever thought what m.c escher mixed
with duplo blocks in a little rainbow
bright color aesthetic mixed in would
look like
identity verified i actually really like
this show but this sure looks like
they're using facial recognition on a
[ __ ] mask that could be worn by
anybody this could be the dumbest
[ __ ] security measure i've ever seen
and i just rewatched home alone damn
that thing has a freaking huge head of
course it does it's like 20 feet tall it
has a huge everything
well then
then on the first one there talking
while instructions are being given i'm
just saying when your brain sprays out
onto the ground slim shady i'll be sure
to pour 40 ounces of i told you so in
your honor player 324
eliminated why did [ __ ] 324 get the
special treatment of having their
elimination announced when everyone else
in the scene just got mowed down like so
many cannon fodder chatari seriously how
is no one getting caught in friendly
fire here i know most of these people
are down on their luck and probably
don't have anyone in their lives that
would notice their disappearance but out
of the couple hundred dead bodies here
at least some of them have a family
member or friend who would care enough
to call the police in fact the only two
people we know so far definitely have
people who would give a [ __ ] if they
didn't come home and all of them will
have disappeared shortly after having a
strange meeting involving a game with a
person who isn't wearing a [ __ ] mask
i'm just saying how do you cover up this
many people disappearing over a short
space of time all under similar
circumstances without eventually being
found out don't look back just listen
but he literally just moved his head so
how is seong not dead now do the
shooters know he's a main character
we've gone through several rounds of
this game now and i'm [ __ ] staggered
at the dumbasses that are still failing
to follow this very simple red light
rule as if their lives didn't [ __ ]
depend on it
show has time for this automated musical
interlude next time on lost
[Music]
do not pass go do not collect two
hundred dollars
i have tasted blood before and that
is not it i don't believe in jesus
the power of christ compels you the
power of christ compels you
you take the blue pill
the story ends
you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe
you take the red pill
you stay in wonderland
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes
call that number
why
they make your life
fun
that man is playing galaga
thought we wouldn't notice
the first rule of fight club is
you do not talk about my club
second rule of fight club is
you do not
talk about fight club
look out ready we're not backing down
because we're the power rangers it's
morphing time
things have certainly changed around
here
i remember when this was all farmland as
far as the eye could see
old man peabody on all of this
he had this crazy idea
about breeding pine trees
[Laughter]
you don't know me but
i know you
i want to play a game
my volunteers tribute